everyone i'm lucy and i'm rachel and
we're solutions architects working at
aws today we're going to be talking a
bit about our journey into aws what the
interview process was like and also what
skills are required to become a
solutions architect rachel to start off
with do you want to introduce yourself
tell the viewers who you are and what
your journey was like yeah of course so
my name is rachel i am a aws solutions
architect just like lucy we're actually
almost basically in the same team
yeah pretty much but i specifically work
with small to medium businesses and yeah
super excited to talk to you today so
rachel today we want to focus more about
your journey because you know we have
you on the show today and i'm sure the
viewers will be interested in hearing
about how you end up becoming a
solutions architect i know you started
off in an architectural degree and then
you became a solutions architect which
by the way are two very different things
but even though they have architect in
the name do you want to talk a bit about
how you were able to make that
transition and why you wanted to make
that change in the first place as well
yeah of course so just to clarify when
we say architecture we mean like for
buildings essentially so i was a
designer before i ended up in tech um
yeah it's definitely not a conventional
journey by any means
but when i was studying my master's
degree so essentially for architecture
you have a bachelor's and a master's i
got my bachelor's halfway through my
master's i realized actually maybe this
isn't this isn't quite for me which is a
little bit late but you know we live and
we learn
but
when i realized that i started attending
things like meetups talking to people in
tech um getting mentors and stuff like
that before i kind of gained the
confidence to essentially be like well
i'm just gonna
stuff all of the years of studying that
i just did
and jump into a masters of i.t
and from that point on that kind of
opened up opportunities for me to go
into grad roles i was a grad at a
consulting company for a while and then
i moved into aws from that job
awesome so for me i studied a bachelor
of information systems at the start i
wanted to become a consultant and looked
into different industries as well and
then you know landed up in tech after
doing an internship at aws i think what
people are really interested in is the
interview process they want to know what
they need to prepare for for an aws
interview and maybe more specific for
the sa role what are some things to look
out for do you want to talk a bit about
your experience and also what sort of
advice you have for people who are going
to be sitting in aws interview yeah for
sure so i mean everyone who's watching
these videos are probably about to go
for an interview or are interested in a
role at aws
so you probably already heard about how
intense the interview process is
i have to agree you know i've never
really been through four back to back
interviews for anywhere else but that
was essentially what i had to do when i
wanted to get this job right so
unfortunately it was all virtual because
we were still in the middle of covert so
it was 2020 essentially right um and
a lot of the questions that i was asked
surprisingly weren't that technical um
in that like you're not being asked to
do a coding interview or anything like
that for essays essentially what they
wanted to focus on was more around
systems design and about what kind of
past projects i've already done and the
design decisions and the rationale for
why i made them yeah so it was technical
in that uh sense but it wasn't like i
had to sit down and code for example or
sit down and explain and also jobs
exactly
so that was kind of against what i
thought was going to happen because you
often hear like you know oh the the
coding interviews at amazon are so hard
all that kind of stuff
i have no idea like i i wouldn't know it
really varies depending on the level
that you're applying for as well also
the type of team with a solution
architect role it's not just about your
coding skills or technical skills right
for sure like oftentimes people think
that because it is a technical role
that's all there is to it but you have
to remember this is a
pretty much
almost 100 client-facing role as well so
your soft skills your business acumen
are all really important as well but
that said when i got into this job i
pretty much had neither of those things
so
that's not true
i mean to some extent right like it was
definitely something that i knew i had
to work on but
you know
it's good to acknowledge that gap in
your skills and work towards it and
that's something you can do on the job
as well
yeah
oh wow so yeah for rachel she did the
four rounds of interviews which is
typically the process for those
full-time roles at aws for me it was a
bit of a shortened process because i
started off as an intern so i had two
amazon loops and um going from an
internship to a graduate role
fortunately i didn't have to do any
additional interviews it was a straight
conversion from my internship to a
graduate role i think for some people
it's kind of like a case-by-case basis
they might be required to do an
additional interview you know after
doing the internship so rachel what i
wanted to ask you next is what skills
are required to become a solutions
architect i think we can both share some
insights into that since we're both
essays but wanted to hear your
perspective first what do you think are
the key skills both technical and
non-tech things that people should be
looking out for if they're interested in
becoming an essay yeah for sure i mean
like we kind of alluded to it a little
bit just then with the fact that i was
missing some of those girls when i
joined i had the technical skills but a
hundred percent like my
um client-facing experience was next to
zero essentially when i joined um i
didn't know how to hold meetings i
didn't know how to speak to
people in c-suite which is essentially
who we are talking to pretty much every
day day in day out um being able to
level set the kind of conversations
we're having depending on the audience
all of those soft skills are really
really important but i think the most
important skill to think about
apart from all the things we've already
spoke about
really is empathy because
really our job as solutions architects
is to understand the kind of business
problems their goals all that kind of
stuff that's actually important to the
customer right
even if we are absolute geniuses in tech
if we're just throwing tech solutions at
them and not really helping them
actually achieve what they want then
you're not really
being very effective as a solutions
architect as well right yeah i
definitely agree with that rachel it's a
lot about empathizing with the customer
and a lot of at the times it's more
about the soft skills and being able to
earn trust with them rather than the
technical skills but technical skills
are also important in the essay role i
wanted to hear perspectives on what do
you think are some things that people
who want to become an essay can work
towards in order to improve their
technical skills yeah i mean i think
technical skills are definitely
important you know you being able to
actually understand common technologies
common patterns common architectures
things like that are really important
for you to be able to advise effectively
right
so
you're not you know expected to know
really really in-depth uh coding um
concepts i suppose i highly recommend
trying to study for some of the sets so
that was how i kind of leveled up my
cloud skills when i first got into this
job because when i came in i basically
had cloud prac and that was it and
i don't think that's really enough for
us to really have uh good conversations
with our customers so going through the
associate solutions architecture uh cert
really really gave me the confidence
maybe not necessarily like really deaf
technical skills but at least the
confidence and the safety blanket that i
needed to
hold those conversations yeah and then
it was notification yeah at the end of
the day it's a multiple choice exam but
it definitely gives you the confidence
to get familiar with some of the 80s
technologies by you know at least
knowing what they do and a lot of those
video courses as well they have some
hands-on lab exercises for you to you
know have a look into the console and
dive a bit deeper and play you know play
around with those services so that's
something we'll i reckon would both
recommend right getting started with
learning adb certifications
but also trying to get a basic technical
understanding of just the common
concepts around networking compute
databases storage yeah
and a lot of it can be self-taught as
well right speaking of self-taught one
of the best ways to learn is to join an
online community and work with others
who have similar goals last month i
started the cloudbytes community which
is a group to bring together our
techwindows subscribers if you're
preparing for an abs certification or
looking to start your career in the
cloud i'd recommend joining the
community on slack alright so this
brings us to the end of this video thank
you rachel for coming onto the channel
and helping answer some of the questions
and also just sharing your journey
getting into aws please remember to give
this video a like if you'd like to see
more videos like this and subscribe to
this channel to stay updated alright bye
for now see you guys
[Music]